good morning everyone good afternoon
maybe
good evening to a few of you i am jeff
blankenberg and as usual we are here
with an episode of alexa and friends
with me today i have the great honor of
having andy breen joining me he's the
senior manager of tts research at amazon
thanks for being here hi
glad to be i'm i'm glad you could be
here too um
so as as we usually do in these
interviews one of the first things that
i like to start with
is some silly questions and i know i've
prepared you only in that there's going
to be some silly questions
but i certainly haven't told you what
these questions are uh and so we'll
start with the first one
uh which i always really enjoy i think
it offers some insight into people
uh if you could choose any one
superpower
for yourself why would you choose it and
which one would it be
okay um you know strangely i do think
about this now and again
but the problem is i'm just too
practical because you know
if you fly right you know if you went
supersonic you'd be burnt to a crisp
very quickly and uh so
you'd have to have more than one
superpower if you're gonna fly uh to
make it actually practically useful
so i i don't know so i sort of think uh
there's a few i like
uh but if i had my own
superpower i think it would be
the ability to know when to stop
something oh
uh i started a lot of stuff i'm a great
starter you know i
you know lots of lots of great
adventures lots of great things
but i'm pretty bad at knowing when it's
time to to
to stop doing something when it's time
to uh
to you know give up and uh
i could think of lots of occasions where
i've watched stock markets go up and
down and i've never known when to sell
so no
knowing when to stop i wonder if that's
just kind of like
um the ability to see into the future a
little bit because i think the reason
for stopping sometimes might be
different right is it because i want to
sell stock
or is it just because this project that
i think is going to be really successful
is end up not going to be very
successful at all so i shouldn't spend
the time on it
i hadn't really thought about that
actually i mean i just think it's like
i'm a great i'm a big amateur painter i
love my art and
uh uh i've got friends who are artists
and sometimes they you know we'll
know i'll be tutored by them and that
one comment to me is that they've seen a
lot of great
paintings come and go because i've just
kept working it and working and working
in an i never know
stop sure is that some of your artwork
behind you
yeah that's that's it that's excellent
yeah that's actually a
a musician called anna calvi um and it
was taken from
one of her videos i got a permission and
i spoke to and she was
all happy to have it done and uh uh they
were really uh
dynamic and i really loved them so
um i decided to to to replicate them in
art form
and uh yeah so i did a set of three and
had a small show to show it so it's all
good fun
very very cool uh all right so so we're
gonna we're gonna call it knowing the
knowing how to stop but i i do feel like
it kind of translates into
future vision of some kind uh but i like
it i think that's a good one
spidey sense i do like the practicality
of flying though we've had many guests
on here that have said flight
and i never really considered the fact
that you wouldn't be able to go that
fast i mean you'd be able to go decently
fast
faster than a car for sure but to go
superman speeds that's that's another
story yeah
it does it's a limiting factor
but what if you could go sonic um but of
course you have the friction problem
what if you could just
duck out into space you go at a
reasonable speed into space
and then go supersonic around the globe
where you don't have the friction
and then duck back down because it'd be
super sonic you don't have to hold your
breath for a few seconds
uh that's something yeah but then you
would then you would explode with lack
of pressure you need
you need you need to have the super
action and then and then fly
you do just all right all right i'll let
that one go um
uh so i have i have a couple of other
questions but uh
being an artist i'm going to see how
this one translates for you maybe you've
given this consent some consideration
have you ever been any kind of musician
in your in your art past
only a bad one i i do i do play guitar
um
i love it i love playing guitar and i
play regularly just with uh
friends this is going to be perfect this
is this is like
some people are like no i've never
touched a musical instrument other than
a recorder in uh early elementary school
so one of the questions i like to ask
people is i want you to imagine these
people that you're playing music
with uh that you form a band and you
decide that you are going to release
your debut album
what is the name of that debut album
oh my god i actually know i now you
throw me completely there
no idea what i would do uh
i guess you know what i this just
literally comes
to the uh to the top of my head i think
i call it something like reflections
um yeah only because you know
i had what people call a significant
birthday relatively recently
and even though i don't like recognizing
asian birthdays and all that sort of
stuff
you you find yourself reflecting on
things you know and uh
i guess i've just been doing a bit of
that recently so
um it would have to be just reflections
uh i like that
i think that's a good one uh well happy
belated birthday and welcome to your 40s
congratulations
indeed yeah
um all right so let's let's also uh
let's wrap up with my favorite question
this is an audience favorite as well
uh and i like to tell a little story
about how this happens so i want you to
imagine you're walking in a busy city
uh and you need to turn down a narrow
alley and not much wider than yourself
but it's an alley between two buildings
and you start heading down that alley
and as you get about halfway there
to the other end of the alley you are
confronted with a
horse sized duck so imagine a very very
large duck
that's about the size of a horse and it
looks very threatening
and so you turn around and you're like i
gotta get out of here and so you look at
the other end of the alley now
and there are 100 horse abduct-sized
horses
so little little tiny houses maybe this
big
they both are aggressive and to survive
you need to get out of this alley
so if you have to fight one side or the
other to get out
what do you choose and why
right interesting
interesting
so a number of what's a duck-sized
forces and a horse-sized duck did you
say
yeah but a hundred a hundred little ones
100 is a lot
see this is the thing you know this is
what i'm thinking
i just think it's a very it's a very
crowded uh
lane you've got me in here as well uh i
think i'm gonna go for the big duck
now you've got to get past it you've got
to get past
the beak the beak is the big problem
there but he's not going to be very
maneuverable he's a big duck
he's not going to be able to turn around
right you know he won't be able to go
backwards and forwards
so i reckon that if i could sort of do a
sort of a shimmy and a dirty dive to get
between his legs i think i'd be out and
under before he could actually
do us any seriously i like it almost
nobody picks the big duck i'm really
impressed that you decided to go that
route i like it
um almost everybody is convinced that
they could somehow get around
a hundred tiny horses and i i just
imagine walking through a beautiful park
big open space and all of a sudden i'm
surrounded on all sides by a hundred
ducks just normal ducks
that's that's intimidating and scary uh
i can't imagine a hundred small horses
being surrounding me that way i think
that would be much much tougher i'm with
you i go big duck every time
yeah they're gonna get one big peck at
you and then they're done but
all right well that that's wonderful
thank you for humoring me with my silly
questions
um all right let's let's get into it one
the the next step that i like to take in
these interviews
is to kind of talk about your background
so i'd love to know more about
you know a little bit about your role
here at amazon maybe end with that
but i'd love to know specifically what
your origin story is like how did you
get to amazon how
what led you to the path that you're on
today
right okay so um well i didn't start out
in speech i started out with
my first degree was in physics with uh
computer physics
um so a long way from speech although i
guess
even back then i must have had a sort of
innate interest in it because
um i ended up doing a third year project
to create a real-time speech recognizer
which was a little again a little bit
out of what they were expecting people
with physics
to do in the third year uh so but i
enjoyed it i didn't get very far but i
did enjoy doing it
um but i had every intention of staying
in um in physics but then when i left
university i had a young family and i
needed to get a job um i looked around i
looked for
hundreds of jobs and i was just very
fortunate to to land the jobs in ra
in the university of liverpool uh in
their speech group and they were doing
uh speech coding back then and another
other speech work um and that was my
first
opportunity to experience uh that area
and i started to enjoy it
and then that was a fixed time contract
for around about three years so i had to
think about again where i've had
and i had to decide whether okay so you
know i've got experience now i managed
to get some
a further research degree when i was at
liverpool they were kind of let me do
that as well
um in engineering so that was cool and
you knew
a new skill um so i had to decide
whether i want to go back to physics or
stay in this the speechy stuff that i'd
started to work on
um and again it was just it was just
pure luck i
applied to two or three different
positions some of them were
physics-related and some of them were
more speech related and
i was just lucky to to to land a job
at uh university college london uh which
is a very well known uh
center for speech and language at uh is
and was at the time
and that was when i really started to
get into into spoken language and
language in general
you know there were so many great people
uh at
that university and we had so many
people from around the world visiting
visiting us you know so you you just
have all the the great names turning up
and giving a lecture on something so it
was a great
tuition um so i was there for a while
and that really got me into it and
actually i
i did a phd there while i was an r.a and
that was in
neural networks that this is the second
time your neural networks turned up they
sort of generated in the 50s and then
they were researching in the gloves
and then i started to do uh
text-to-speech using neural networks way
back when um
and that's my original phd uh and then i
left
um ucl and uh and joined
uh british telecom bt labs as they're
known
which is i guess similar to what people
if they remember att labs when it was a
monopoly
you know there were these big research
labs that the telcos
had a few years ago and i joined the
british version of that
and again i was just really fortunate i
landed on a research project that was
looking at
spoken dialogue systems is going to be a
trained
timetable system believe it or not um
and in my first year though i had the
opportunity to work with uh professor
steven from
cambridge university and he just
developed a well-known toolkit called
htk
which is was a research toolkit for
for working with hidden markov models in
asr and so that was a real education
itself just
just being having the opportunity to
work this new in this new kit
um and then maybe a year or so later i
moved in
back into to text-to-speech uh
eventually becoming the lead there and
then
as the career progressed in bt i was
given the opportunity to manage some
other projects so
i looked at talking heads um
and distributed
dialogue systems which which were
consisted of multiple
machines communicating together to
produce a
distributed dialogue environment uh and
then after
after bt uh after you know i think kind
of reminding 11 or so
years of bt a while i decided to go back
into academia i became a senior lecturer
at the university of east anglia
uh in the uh computing department there
and um
i was i was really lucky that uh bt had
given the opportunity to do some work uh
there for them
as a contract so i worked um
on some research there on ai for a
couple of years and
at the same time i was i was still
involved in speech synthesis and still
developing uh census systems
and uh i started to build a small
company and then ended up
collaborating with another company uh on
on
selling building and selling tts systems
um
and that's when i met up with nuance
which was a startup
silicon valley startup at the time and
with the intention of selling to my
my system but in the end they ended up
buying me in the end
so i i um i started the uh the tts arm
of
the of the nuance uh company and then
i've done many things in in nuance uh i
did
you know lots of different positions but
always really i was in the texas
speech space and then you know i just
just felt it was time for change a new
challenge you know and um
i was very lucky to to get the
opportunity
to to come and work at amazon and it's
been just a real roller coaster
fantastic
adventure ever since i've been here uh
and it was a at a great time i mean
you know the the technology had just uh
had a new spurt of life and so i i've
been riding that particular
roller coaster for the last three years
you've been in amazon for three years
uh yeah i i just hit my four-year
anniversary
uh and i agree with you man this this
has been
one of those adventures that i never
thought i'd find myself in i obviously
don't have a
deep background in voice uh but i have a
deep background in software development
and so
being able to take apart some of the
amazing things you guys are building
and be able to use those to build really
compelling experiences for people that's
uh man this has been just quite an
adventure for me so there was there was
a theme in your history that you just
shared there
um which was luck you often said i was
very lucky i was in the right place at
the right time
i i personally am not i'm not a big
believer in luck i believe that we make
our own
uh and i think more than likely you call
yourself lucky but it was probably
making the right opportunities doing the
right research putting yourself in the
right positions
whether you do it consciously or not i
think that's probably what leads to
these kinds of
great stories but uh boy that was a that
was a rich awesome history thank you for
sharing that
yeah i'll go halfway with you i mean i
think with all
everything in life you've got to take
the opportunities when they come along
um and if you don't i i don't like
regret
so well that's that comes back to the
first question right i'd rather
try something and go for uh then think
oh i wish i'd done that you know
life's too short for me i agree uh 100
agree so so you've you've had quite a
long
tenure in the the world of speech
synthesis and tts
what what's the thing that's kind of
kept you rooted what
can you imagine a scenario where like
you would have gone a completely
different route in physics or something
like that what would that have even
looked like
that's a that's a yeah great question um
have to say i didn't really have any
intention of moving into the speech and
language field
um i'd always always enjoyed in my uh
physicist
as a child and they were my sort of
heroes and people like richard feynman
who was a tremendous character and a
tremendous physicist at the same time
so i guess i wanted to emulate those
those are my heroes at the time and uh
i was torn between cosmology and uh the
other end of the scale you know atomic
physics and uh
certainly enjoyed both those those
topics but
well i never i don't as i say you know
whether it's luck or whether it was
something in me that
that drove me back into the speech and
language area i'm not sure but
i guess there was that always has been a
um
an interest in in what it is to be human
as well
what makes us who we are and and whether
there is a divine spark or whether
actually we can
become deconstructed and re you know and
built built up in some sort of
uh analog through a computer so i guess
that that's always uh
that's always intriguing that's an
interesting perspective on it that i
hadn't heard before that
you're you're trying to see how close we
can get to real humanity
i mean that's something we always talk
about right we want to we want to be
able to have voice assistance in any
kind of text-to-speech system
be able to behave as much like a human
as possible
but it does we as we continue to
progress down this path it does raise
that question
of what is humanity versus what is uh
synthetic
that's a it's a really really deep
question that i don't think we're going
to answer in this hour for sure but
uh now half of me wishes that we
never will but the other half we want to
burningly uh
answer questions i will tell you this is
not one thing you should stop on
you it's not time to stop yet let's keep
going um
all right so i have i have another
question uh
primarily based on on your history i
mean you talked about
you know neural networks being around
even in the 50s and 60s and
how they've seen a resurgence um
how have you seen the technology evolve
like what are the major advancements
that you've seen since the early days in
tts
yeah um so i was really lucky
i'm really again i'm using the word luck
but i do feel very lucky you're
fortunate
to have seen uh two major uh
shifts in technology really seismic
shifts in the technology
when i when i was a young guy and i
started in this there were
um there are a few gods of
people around people like uh dennis
clatton and gunner fans and john holmes
who were very famous at the time and
in their in their space and they were
working in the combination of hardware
software
uh with predominantly hardware because
the computers at the time
just weren't capable of emulating these
things
uh uh fully in software that changed in
the 80s when when
computers started to take off and they
were using mathematical models
and the models were they they were
relatively basic uh in in terms of
what they could achieve and so the
quality of synthesis that were produced
by these models
was less than perfect let's just put it
right back i mean any model of
life is an approximation and and the
detail is
what is what makes it uh life special
right and so models tend to smooth that
out and
these things they they were losing the
fine
granularity of what makes speech
speech so uh but they were very very
impressive mathematical models all the
same
um but we'd reach this sort of see
plateau a glass ceiling of quality
um and i don't know whether it's because
uh
the uh digital revolution was happening
and cellular phones were coming out
and people were thinking differently
about the topic um
there was this this new uh thought
the thought was let's not try and model
speech
let's see if we can just encode the
speech
and then stick it together and and
regurgitate it i mean i'm being very
simplistic about it but this was a
radical idea at the time um and
only really possible because of the the
emergence of
significant computing power that allowed
us to do it but i was really there at
the beginning and i was fortunate
to be one of the founders of this
technology which
just transformed the uh the ability
of uh text-to-speech from something that
was
used only really for
for a very niche
applications um for example uh helping
people who lost their voice uh the
famous one of course being
uh stephen hawkings uh they were used in
that application but they weren't used
broadly in in society
and then when these concatenative
systems came out
they jumped the quality to a level that
was
um acceptable to the general public
people say oh yeah that's a voice that i
can listen to
and also the way technology works we
could sort of
fool the system into being very natural
for specific phrases so
uh it it it just shifted the whole
uh game really from being an interesting
side area
to an area that that could really
influence everyday life
uh with the interactive voice response
systems that you saw in the 90s coming
out
so speech simpsons took off it took off
um
through the 90s into the 40s um and of
course
there were huge advances there but again
we
we were cheating right we instead of
having a model
we just decided to sidestep it by
storing
our lack of knowledge uh we just stored
and
said well i will sort out the naturalist
problems sometime in the future
uh and uh we got a long way with that
approach
um but but we you could see this this
another glass eating
approaching where we thought boy you
know we we've we've sort of
taken you know squeezed the pips out of
this idea but we we just had no real
idea about how to
take uh this technology further and
there wasn't really any clear signs that
uh the the models that
were around we're gonna we're gonna
achieve that and then
neural networks are emerged again as
being a significant
um technology and again that was coupled
with um
increases in computer power and that was
the second revolution where we could
now think of models again
instead of sidestepping these issues and
we could think of modeling speech again
using these neural networks
um and that's that's that's just opened
up a whole new world for us again
so so neural networks seem to be the
path towards the future that's that's
where a lot of the
at least from my perspective we see that
in things like amazon poly
and a number of other texas speech
services so when
when alexa launched and i know you
weren't here at the launch but um
was there a time at which alexa was more
a concatenative system
and moved to neural or is this something
that's always been neural the whole time
oh not at all no we uh um in
2014 when when alexa was launched
um the the system was a concave system
and uh it was an extremely good
concatenate system as
i would testify as uh i worked for
competitors and i was always gauging
how we were doing against how uh amazon
alexa's voice was doing and thinking boy
they're good um so it's it's
uh it's it's a great technology um um
but it's quite
constrained you know it's good at what
it does but it was it was fundamentally
limited
so it beating it was one of the
challenges you know
before you can release a new technology
you know
it can't be any worse than the the
current technology
um and so that was our first challenge
was to actually demonstrate that we had
another technology
that that could offer the same quality
um and also opportunities for the future
and of course all new technologies bring
their own challenges it's never it's
never
that you've got a completely new idea
that just
slots into place perfectly you know the
new technologies
uh were heavier they are heavier than
capacitive systems and there was a lot
of
scratching of heads to to to uh to make
them work
uh but yeah we moved to neurals
relatively recently with the first
launch uh being in 2018
i remember right excellent all right so
we're going to get back a little bit
into your history uh you mentioned that
you were a senior lecturer
at the university of east anglia um and
you were talking about
uh the research contract from bt that
you had but what you didn't talk about
in your history
was that you were actually doing a bunch
of work with virtual reality
environments too right
so tell me about that like i have like a
few virtual reality helmets here in my
house
and my family absolutely love the
concept and i can see a ton of practical
applications outside of the games that
we generally play
but tell me more about what you were
doing with vr
yeah it was pretty cool stuff actually
it's great fun um
there was a fashion at the time to have
these virtual
reality cubes where people would would
step inside
and be surrounded literally by uh
walls of screens that would would
display virtual environments
and uh and all that would be there would
be sort of uh
uh walls that wrapped around you
um and we would you display reality onto
that or virtuality onto that we were in
that camp so we had a big wall right a
huge wall that wrapped around you and
you were surrounded by speakers
um that that spatially
you know place the sound spatially
around you and
um uh the the idea was
uh to to to play around these ideas of
of uh again what it means to be
independent as an ai and and uh
but in an entertaining way and so we
wanted to play around with distributed
intelligence
uh intelligence that could learn from
its environment
and and the theory was um that
we real world is too complicated it's
just too
complicated uh to try and uh to capture
everything
but if we simplify the world if we
created a world where an ai
could live within it and then and
actually practically know
pretty much everything there is about
that world could that could that agent
then start to learn things and interact
with a human being
um and one of the things we did for
example was the human being would
uh play a game of hide and seek where
where you'd run away and hide behind a
pillar
and the agent would have to search the
environment and try and find you and it
was a great thing to do
because you you'd see these rays of uh i
don't know
virtual light coming out from the uh
from the agent and then hitting a wall
and coming back to the agent and it
would see
so you can actually see how it's mapping
its environment
um and of course the human being would
communicate
in to with the world through natural
language so you'd say
you know go to room five or take me over
there you know and
so it was common it was combining all
sorts of functions that's
that's super cool um i've i've uh i've
had
a decent amount of experience with
virtual reality and it's just been
the way that it can immerse and the idea
of applying ai to that is really
quite compelling uh to be able to have
uh even a simple
game like hide and seek i think being
able to play something that is
so traditionally human with uh with
something uh that isn't
is uh that's exciting to me uh and i
know that that was a while
back but still those kinds of concepts
still really haven't found their way
into
the commonplace uh experiences yet today
so i'm looking forward to
the future and where that all lands
yeah it's great fun of course we had
about 10 computers and specialist
hardware
you could probably yeah i was actually
wondering when you were first doing all
of
this stuff were you were you running a
lot of your models and things on
computers the size of
you know houses
well we know because we were going down
a different route where
um everything was about distribution so
instead of having one big computer you
specialized
a computer to a particular area
um sound vision whatever you know and uh
and so we may have like five or six
uh computers running simultaneously and
then there was this
ludicrously complex software uh that
created a sort of virtual software
environment uh
coding environment where it appeared
that all the systems were
in one uh in one place
yeah oh that's that's very cool you've
you've had some incredible experiences
uh
so so we recently had uh goku turon here
um and he was able to talk about some of
the new alexa capabilities related to
turn taking
and for the ability for customers to
teach alexa
and we also had at our devices event in
september i know that um
we had some folks on talking about
speech-driven advancements can you can
you talk to that a little bit tell us
more about
uh those topics yeah sure
so um as i mentioned to you the first
thing is to make
is to make sure that you're natural
right you have to sound natural
um but that's a very vague term and um
we sort of constrain the term natural
uh to allow us to make progress in it
but it's a pretty broad sort of speech
and it was a broad sort of speech
because that worked and uh
we wanted but it's never gonna really go
where we wanted to go because human
beings
as we were talking about what is it to
be human um
well one of the one of the one of the
very human things to do is
is to associate what it is to be human
with voice
um you know and it's so so full of
nuances with the way we speak we express
so much through our language and and the
words we use the way we say them
um that this is obviously where we want
to head
and and and traditional text-to-speech
systems
would analyze text they would say okay
here's the text i want to analyze they
want to extract knowledge from it and
then i want to synthesize that
and that's a really challenging problem
in itself don't get me wrong it's a
hugely challenging problem
um but of course the other aspect that
we work on
is um dialogues so you want to be
working and talking with an agent
and and what we've recently started to
look at
is is making our systems what we call
contextually aware
or unadaptive so in other words um
when when you have a conversation with
an agent
um you want to be able to be adapting
the synthesis to how the discourse is
going
you know just change changing it subtly
so that
the way you respond gives the the uh the
interlocutor
the sense that you're hearing them that
you're responding
in a way that makes sense for a human
being so we've been looking at adjusting
um our speech the tone the stress on the
words
how we pause even even emulating how we
breathe anything that makes it sound
more natural
without trying to fool people we're not
pretending as a human being there but we
want to
cue into what's natural for human beings
uh you know
applying that to um to
systems so that so that we can change as
the
as the dialogue progresses got it
very cool so i want to know a little bit
more about this so we have we have this
concept of neural text-to-speech
and what you're describing is kind of
neural text-to-speech synthesis
um okay let's just start at the
beginning
can you talk about the foundations of
neural text to speech first and then
kind of lead into
how synthesis changes that
sure so um so it takes us back to
concatenate synthesis i guess
and and how and how that started
i said what can catholicism exist
concatenative systems
existed and there are another class of
systems that you call let's call them
uh parametric systems or systems that
again come back to having a model so you
either model or you encode
these are the two basic approaches if
your model right you you have a set of
parameters
you push the parameters through your
model and it and it says something
but as i mentioned earlier the challenge
with these models are that you could you
could
change the parameters in any way you
like and so it was very flexible you
could make
a squeaky voice or a deep voice you
could make it really fast or really slow
um but what you can never do was make it
sound completely human
it lacked that that that knowledge
uh to be able to convert the model into
something that sounded very human so
you always you always have this feeling
of of quality
what's called segmental quality as well
as uh other types of uh quality which
are called prosody so two types of
speech
segmental quality is the the actual
sound that comes out of ease the as he
goes
and the positive the rhythm that goes
along with it
um so we were lacking the ability of
these
models to be able to really get the fine
quality out so
i want to i want to answer a second this
is incredibly interesting but you you
prompted a question in my head which is
that it didn't sound entirely natural
how
how do we in the science world how do we
define natural
how is it just something that you have
to subjectively
observe or is there some way or is there
some amount of
um measurement you can use to say this
one sounds human this one doesn't
oh i wouldn't ask without question it's
such a hard question
what is natural right um you don't have
to answer that question that's too hard
i know it's a problem
it's just such a difficult one and then
there are there are
analogies in other areas right so um
naturalism is a very subjective thing
for a start i mean i mean you've
probably heard of the uh
uh the gap yeah i can't remember namely
the quality gap that
that is commonly mentioned that you've
got something that as it approaches
human-like uh it suddenly starts to look
slightly eerie so um
uh when you when you've got uh ai's
which are you know
human close in terms of the way they
look
when talking heads you know people often
complain because they look slightly dead
they look slightly
creepy you know and the uncanny value
thank you i
couldn't find the word that you just
found it the uncanny valley is exactly
that
um and you have the same thing in speech
um
that it just doesn't sound right it's
not hitting
the the brain is hardwired probably
to to look out for certain acoustic cues
and
um if as a human being you do it without
even thinking
the speech contains all the information
at the right time in the right way
for you to decode it as efficiently as
possible
and one this is the side point but very
interesting one
one of the things people always say is
it's robotic um what it isn't uh because
if you think about hollywood robots and
the one thing about hollywood robots is
you can understand them
it doesn't matter which robot they are
you can always understand them
so the actor of course is is making sure
that the information gets across the
other human being but
there's a veneer of of aliens that they
put on it they may
make the pitch a bit flatter or there
may be some sort of reverberation
applied to it
but because as a human being all the
right information is there
when you actually go to the real world
and you're actually trying to get a
computer to do this
it doesn't have that and so it can do
things that
will really unnerve a human being or
just not play right
or put a load on a mental load on people
that means that they have to slow the
voice down because they can't quite
understand what he's saying
calling back to like the stephen hawking
voice right i mean it has that same
property where like you are very aware
that you're listening to a computer
generated voice and it is hard to listen
to for a long period of time because you
just
you can't follow and there's no beats
and there's there's none of the stuff
that you have naturally that's
boy that's incredibly interesting all
right so i i interrupted you you were
talking about
neural text of speech and i want to get
you back to that i just uh i had to ask
that question
okay okay yeah yeah i forgot what we
were talking about as well
um so yeah so there was the model
approach and the models always lack this
this something extra um and then we we
talked about the concat system which
is just about uh encoding sounds
um and it's much more complicated than
that of course because
um you can read you can record sounds
and
going back to why the first speech that
was was produced with
can caster system sounded bored it's
because we were trying to stop
um trying to reduce the number of
variabilities
in the voice so if we just if we just
said to the voice and
just sound the same whatever you're
speaking and talk to you like this and
then
you know we we can actually then cut
bits of sound out from anywhere
and then put them somewhere else if
there's if
each sound has got um a
high emotional content to it you it's
stuck in that emotional environment
if you take the emotion out you can
stick it anywhere so
so the neutral slightly dead in the
voice was because it allowed us to move
sounds around
without that penalty but of course you
still have to be able to select the
right
sound at the right time and so the
concatenation systems are really all
about
how do i record the right sounds what's
the minimum number recordings i can get
away with because it's expensive and
time consuming to do and which is the
right sound to select
at the right point for the for the
synthesis so it's all about selection
and we did start to move towards
uh hybrid systems that use neural
technology
to select sounds but it was still
limited by what you recorded
sure and then there was these emerging
technologies around deep neural networks
that appeared around about 2016
and they've demonstrated that the latest
neural models
could uh be used to generate sounds
again so
going back to generating sounds in a
more general way
but they were also able to
capture and regenerate this
this something extra this this this
element of quality
in human voice uh that we were unable to
capture
with the earlier models so all of a
sudden we now had a
a a mathematical approach if you like a
model approach
that promised to be able to do all the
things that our older models have done
in terms of flexibility
and yet potentially seem to offer us
this
quality that was lacking before um and
that was the big breakthrough and where
uh and where we've started to to
capitalize on
and so just just for the people that are
watching is is there any examples of
how we're capitalizing on that or how
we're making use of that in in ways they
may have seen or heard
uh for alexa yeah for sure
um the first thing we did of course
is as i mentioned was that we we had to
demonstrate we were as good as
and that was the first thing we did and
we and we did that it took a bit of time
the the always the one the empty piece
of paper is always the hardest thing you
know once you've got something down in
it you can start
to to clean it up um and once we've
demonstrated that
we then wanted to ask the question what
more could we do
and so actually one of the first
products we produced wasn't just this
natural
flat voice that uh that's been available
for all the years proceeding with
catholic technology we said we asked the
question well
what come what could we do different and
one of the things that
came to mind was well how about seeing
if we can replicate
a style of speaking so
one of the key areas that people always
think about to think about
text-to-speech is news reading
so how about we see if we can get one
these systems to learn
what it is to be a newscaster to to pick
up the the newscaster-ish
global style if you like you know
uh of speaking that way and so that's
what we attempted to do we are
we trained the system on a mix of of
of neutral style voice and then injected
into that
um recordings that we said to a voice
teller okay
pretend you're a newscaster pretend you
know you're going to read the news
and so we injected in that material as
well
and then we taught the system to
recognize the difference between the two
um and then when you wanted the system
to speak in a newscaster style
you you gave it that instruction i said
okay i should be speaking like this now
and lo and behold we were pleasantly
surprised to see that it did capture
um this this this um this property
uh and we were able to launch with um
the newscaster style
to to read a news flash on fresh
briefings that's been a lot of fun to
play with so it's it's cool to see
how all of this science and research and
effort goes into
making something that can be so
impactful to a lot of people and they
don't
they don't necessarily think about how
that all works behind the scenes
but synthesizing a newscaster voice
can't be easy uh i i've got to imagine
that
um there was a lot of work that went
into just capturing that one
kind of speaking style
yeah we did we took a we took a bit of
time to get it right um
one one of the problems is that if you
if you say to somebody
act this unless they're an extremely
good actor or actress then uh
they they're unable to do that right
they're gonna it's gonna come across as
as fake and we didn't wanna we didn't
want the sound of a fake newscaster we
wanted the sound of a real newscaster
so um we took a great deal of time with
the actor
to uh to to allow them
to get into and understand in their own
mind what it what what it takes to speak
in that style
so they probably went through the same
thing as our machines
they they actually probably socialized
in their in their neural network uh
how i should be thinking when i when i
when i speak as a newscaster
and uh they generalize that
they they sort of turned that into
something that they could reproduce and
so they they could reproduce it and
since they could reproduce it
we could discriminate them doing so and
then we could teach the machine to do
the same thing which is which is what we
did but we took a long time making sure
we we got the uh the real sense of
newscast that's fantastic
all right so we've talked about neural
tts and some of the techniques and
technologies
how has alexa's tts become more advanced
over time
well so there are different stages that
i think
we've gone through uh i've mentioned
already that you the first thing to do
is to become
more natural right and then that was
that's that that's day one
uh of the the new world uh day two is
saying okay well let's see if we can uh
apply some styles to it let's see if we
can capture broad
sweeps of a particular way of speaking
and uh and that worked so that worked
pretty well
and then of course the natural extension
from that is well style is what is style
it's difficult to
pin down it's it's a way of speaking but
um of course expressivity of an
expression of motion is also very
important and we're often asked well can
the synthesizer
apply a particular emotion so the next
thing to try and say okay let's see
can these systems uh learn an emotion
and so we we again we did a similar sort
of approach where we got
a voice actor to um
express emotions um and then
we took a slightly different attack here
uh we didn't tell we well we did tell
the system this is a motion a this is a
motion b
but it was at a very high level and then
we used
a technique called disentangle um
which which allowed us to then build up
a sort of what's called an embedded
space of
of uh a representation of emotion
in this space and then you can navigate
through this space and put
put a point there and say what's that
sound like oh it sounds like you're
really excited
put a point there what does that sound
like oh it sounds like you're really
depressed
so you're able once you've got this
space you'll be able to navigate around
it then you'll be able to delimit areas
that clearly represented an emotion to a
human being
and so once we had these areas then we
could tell the system all right i want
you to be in that area when you speak
and would lo and behold then that the
voice would actually
sound happier because it was drawing its
knowledge from this
this embedding space and this in this
area that is that is so cool
um there's there's something else i want
to get to um
there was a interesting publication um
authored by the members of your team
actually
it was accepted at uh i think there's a
conference this week inner speech 2020
is this week
um and it's related to singing synthesis
uh
this has really intrigued me so using
computer models to synthetic synthesize
a human singing voice i mean
um i i like to think of myself as an
amateur futurist and think about what
the world will look like in 10 or 15 or
50 years
uh and as i read about this i was just
so perplexed by the idea of
computers being able to not only sing
but potentially compose entire songs
with lyrics
uh all on their own so i'd love to know
more about
what the advancements look like on
speech singing synthesis
so yeah so that that's that was as you
write as a paper and singing since this
has came out into speech which is
happening around about now
um uh many of the techniques are very
similar so
so the way if we take a step back the
way
that we've approached a lot of these
problems is we've broken the problem
into
into two parts and the first part is
um it's about taking a a knowledge
source
text or it could be sheet music um
and then extracting from that knowledge
source
all the information needed uh all the
information contained in it
and then representing that in a vector
or vectors
of extracted knowledge and that's that's
called encoding that's an encoding phase
um and then once we've got that
extracted knowledge
and we then apply that to the second
part of the first part
which is to take it and translate it
into another representation so this is
called sequence to sequence modeling
and probably the easiest way of
describing it is in terms of language
translation so you've got
one language french and you want to
convert that language into english
so you you you suck all the knowledge
out of the friend sentence and you store
it in a
in a representation and then and then
you take that
representation and you decode it
using a model that's been co-trained
into it into a sequence that's english
and
and it's it does feel very magical that
you can do that but this
this is the squeezing knowledge and then
expanding knowledge is called sequence
to sequence modeling
and um that's one of the tricks that's
commonly used
for for all our modeling techniques and
in
singing synthesis as i say we would take
the uh
the score and the words and we take that
in
um and then we would use that as part of
the input sequence and then we would
decode that
to um to the decoded sequence which is
we should then use to generate speech a
critical aspect of this is something
called a tension
um these tech these techniques of
encoding a sequence and then
decoding a sequence really only work
well
when you can attend to the right bit at
the right time
so the analogy that's often uh used when
you think about attention is to imagine
a human being looking at a picture
you don't look at the whole picture at
the same level you'll attend to
different parts of it that are important
to you and uh
there's an analogy in acoustics where
you would want to attend
to the right uh bit of knowledge at the
right point
uh in the acoustic decoding so that you
get the right sound
and so this is this is one of the
critical things that the paper has
has has posited that by using attention
um you don't need other bits of
information you can just go with the
score and the words
and the network is able to to deduce
from that
the other information it needs wow
all right so singing is interesting and
it sounds like it's uh
it's the next evolution it's just adding
more data to your
to your uh your your training um
what about something broader i think a
lot of people probably have are familiar
with samuel l jackson's voice on alexa
um tts is obviously a key part of how
all of that works can ca was there any
reason
i guess there were some recent
advancements in that is that something
you can talk about
sure well uh obviously customers love
the alexa voice but but they also love
to play around with other voices and uh
we've known this because you know we've
had things like jokes with
uh jimmy fallon and uh and chelsea
handler i think did the duet with that
shirt and so on so
we know that these things are things
that people enjoy
and we had an opportunity to to create
um a samuel jackson voice
which we we knew would delight customers
and uh that was launched and in fact in
september we actually advanced on what
the initial launch was
because because we're always trying to
deliver
what the customer needs to make an
experience that they're going to enjoy
and one of the things we we discovered
was what people really wanted to be able
to say was
hey sam just just just go straight in
there and start to talk to samuel
jackson so we've just launched now a new
wake word so that you can go in
and instead of having to say um alexa
may i talk to sam
you can actually say hey sam and and uh
you know sam
will will read back things like weather
and jokes and more
so uh yeah we just just updated that and
it's a it's a very exciting and
entertaining yeah
so so anybody that has that skill
because you that was a skill you had to
purchase as i recall
um if you have that skill enabled you
should be able to just say hey sam to
your device and it'll
pick up do i have to do any
configuration or settings with that
no just just to go hey sam once it's set
up then it's already good to go well as
soon as i get off this i'm gonna have to
give that a try i didn't realize we
could do that now
uh i've i've played with sam a little
bit but i haven't uh i haven't been able
to call just that way that's that's
wonderful
all right so looking forward
which is not something i get to do
terribly often on this channel
what does the next evolution of alexis
voice look like
how do you continue to improve it how do
you make it seem more human what are
what are the steps that we're taking to
try to accomplish those kinds of things
yeah so
the one so when we speak as human beings
we speak for a reason
it's about it's a communication channel
um
it's about giving information to
somebody or giving a performance to
somebody
but we speak for a reason and so behind
every uh style every emotion
there is a motivation there's a reason
for it
and as i mentioned to you earlier you
know reasons
change from second to second depending
on how your conversation is going
depending on what's being what
information is given to you so
um we need to always think about what's
motivating the reason to speak um and
that that requires us to extract
knowledge
uh from information from text so for
example if
we're reading a news article we need to
be able to extract
uh the intention of the author of the
author of the article so that we can
pull out
um not only the style but the meaning
behind style about what's important
whether it's a
a happy event or a sad event or a
challenging event we want to be able to
pull out
that meaning and speak it in a way that
is
fluid and natural and gets across the
right meaning
and as and as i said to you uh we've
been thinking of contextual awareness
and adaption
it's about being able to um extract that
knowledge
um and then apply it back in a way
that engages with the user uh from
from a dialogue perspective or if we're
just reading back knowledge as well so
it's
it's about being able to move forward
and adapt to the environment to the
person into the context
awesome all right last question uh
before we wrap up here i can't believe
we only have five minutes left
um besides the adaptive speaking
and emotion stuff we just talked about
are there any other customer facing
improvements maybe things that people
have an alexa device that may uh may be
familiar with but
is there anything specifically that
you've worked on that you're the most
proud of something that's
really impacted our customers
[Music]
so it's early days uh in in this new
world
and there's so many ideas we've got um
and the one i've pretty much expressed
you the big picture
about where we're going with adaption
and context awareness
and i think those are the new frontiers
being able to get this sense of
of of knowing and being aware are
through the voice but the thing that
i've been proud of i think
in this first three years is he's uh
taking
the team and it was a team of you know
obviously it's a team event you know a
team activity and
uh there were real hurdles that we had
to get through to to get this new
technology up and running
and we've been heads down running as
fast as we could
just to stand still really in terms of
technology because it's such a
fast-paced area
that i think i'm really proud of just
getting the neural technology out there
that just getting it out
broadly to people um with the quality
that we've achieved
at the at the technical cost that we've
achieved because
it was an expensive technology you know
you look right gpus and all sorts of
uh hardware so we've had to scratch our
heads and work
really hard to keep that quality high
while making it cost effective
so that we can actually uh get it out
there
broadly uh to our customers and that's
that was a great ride
so that's probably what i'm most proud
of at the moment excellent um
so i want to note that i know there's
been a bunch of interesting
blogs that cover specifically the alexa
speaking style
adaptation that you've been talking
about as much as a bunch of other
science advances that were announced
last week on amazon.science and i think
uh we've got a link actually to some of
the related tts content that's on amazon
science
and we're going to drop that here in the
chat if you
all watching here would like to learn
about these announcements about what
andrew and the rest of the alexa science
teams are doing
or even some of the scientific endeavors
going on across amazon
please check out amazon science uh we
post all sorts of information there
including these videos and these
recordings so if you'd like to know more
amazon.science is definitely your
destination so
with that uh andy i can't thank you
enough for taking the time this morning
uh to share your perspectives on this i
know i learned a lot i'm sure that our
audience did as well
um is there do you have any parting
thoughts or anything before we head out
no i'm completely blind perfect uh well
as my name is blankenberg i'm
consistently blank
i completely understand uh well i want
to thank you again so much for being
here
and thank the audience certainly for
tuning in uh and we will talk with
everyone again soon thank you again andy